shoppers come to Beijing son Yuen Li
market to buy all kinds of imported
foods including American grown cherries
but it's fast becoming a casualty of
China's trade war with the US tariffs
have already gone up twice pushing the
price of a killer to around $25 and from
September the first tariffs on US
cherries will be raised from 50 to 60
percent vendors are looking for cheaper
alternatives Chinese fruits are very
good the price is much cheaper than
American products the quality is also
very good so more and more people are
choosing local fruits higher prices
aren't the only reason shoppers are
considering buying less from the US for
me being patriotic is something more
important for me to consider than the
price may our Chinese and we are all
affected by the china-us treat war
cherries may be the most popular
American product and this market but
it's not the only fruit that will
receive higher tariffs new duties will
also apply to things like American
thumbs grapes and apples 75 billion
dollars worth of u.s. goods will see
tariffs are between five and ten percent
China will also reinstate import taxes
of 25 percent on US cars in December the
hikes are the Chinese government's
response to the Trump administration's
latest trade war salvo 10 percent
tariffs on 300 billion dollars worth of
Chinese goods also coming into effect in
September and December analysts say the
US president has been a confusing and
unreliable negotiating partner I don't
take the president Trump's remarks
seriously because it is always changing
he also makes the stick bigger in order
to push you let's talk that you must get
you here to me because I have a much
bigger stick China's commerce ministry
says it doesn't want to escalate
tensions and is open to more talks with
the US but it's warned against under
estimating China's willingness to dig
its heels in for the long fight if you
fight you will fight back if you talk
good let's talk but we have principles
we will never yield on principles
weakening its currency and developing
new trade partnerships China's taking
steps to ensure its economy is less
vulnerable to any new moves by Trump in
the trade war and as demand for things
like US cherries slows China's fighting
cheaper alternatives from countries such
as Pakistan and Chile are ripe for the
picking
Katrina you al-jazeera Beijing